hi I'm Erik Bosse and the ventures
endgame just revealed a major update
about the fates of all the key players
in the MCU and they did it in tweet form
giving me an excuse to break down subtle
social media details and necessary
fabricate evidence to form crackpot
theories and another new rockstars tweet
down Marvel Studios dumped a bunch of
character posters for the upcoming
Avengers in-game with the slogan avenge
the Fallen half of these characters are
depicted in color including the core
Avengers Captain Marvel Scott Lang
rocket nebula coy as some others and
survivors whose fates we were a little
less certain of like Valkyrie Wang
Pepper Potts and happy Hogan Valkyrie we
can assume escaped from the Asgardian
refugee ship in the opening minutes of
infinity war we did see what looked like
some escape pods maybe departing from
that wreckage and Thanos may have
allowed half he has guardians to escape
since he's always been a 50% off kind of
guy and Wong Benedict Wong revealed
recently is still alive guarding the
sanctum sanctorum filling in as
replacement sorcerer supreme meanwhile
the other half of posters depicted the
Fallen in black and white including all
the characters who dusted away after
Thanos is snap and once in Thanos killed
in other ways like Loki Gamora
envisioned but most shockingly shuri
younger sister of T'Challa black panther
we have made past videos speculating on
her whereabouts the last time we saw her
alive was in Avengers infinity war in
her lab in Wakanda getting knocked off a
platform by Corvus glaive of the Black
Order and lying motionless on the floor
shuri's faces showed up in the first
Avengers endgame trailer on the screen
and Avengers HQ depicting missing
persons but since Scott Lang showed up
on that screen as well and he did he
dust he was just stuck in the quantum
realm we just assumed her status could
just be unknown but this poster dump
with Shuri in black and white is a
pretty clear indicator from Marvel that
Sheree is indeed fallen dead or dusted
not simply missing you know weaving
together vibranium in the middle of the
jungles of Wakanda and tattooing Thanos
his name on her knuckles
so the way I see it sure he could have
died in one of three ways first that
blow from Corvus glaive could have been
deadlier than we thought every watch
this scene closely it does happen fast
bullet this is a purdue film this as
Corvis fights his way to get to vision
sharee turns and fires a couple blasts
at him to hold him back he deflects the
blast and then he slashes at her but she
obeyed
Corvus attack missed instead he slices
through her tech table and then sure he
ducks out of the way as a door melash a
guard jumps into attack sending the
guard and the slice table smashing
through the glass guardrail sure he
jumps with them and she hits the raised
platform before rolling onto the floor
and you can see her wincing probably
from the pain of the landing but there's
no wound visible now of course this is
Marvel and they don't tend to linger on
close-ups of massive bloody gashes and
he'll even Tony Stark gotten bailed on
Titan he was able to spray some Windex
or whatever on it to seal it up and with
what Coty's famously advanced medical
technology I assume this cut wouldn't
kill her also notice how Corvis briefly
turns to Shuri as if to finish the job
but he stopped by vision knocks him
through the window so I don't think this
attack killed Shuri
the second option of course is that
Shuri could have dusted it happened a
half the living creatures on the planet
including billions off-screen so odds
are Shuri could have been caught up in
the snap wave but I just find it a
little odd that the montage at the end
of infinity war would reveal the fates
of every other key player in the Wakanda
battle including mbaku fighting out
riders in the battlefield and not
include a shot of Shuri dusting as well
yes Wang pepper and happy hogan are
supporting characters whose fates
weren't shown either but they were back
in New York they plead zero role in this
crucial battle so there must be a reason
that we didn't see Cherise final moments
now a third option is that Shuri could
have fallen in some other way and some
off-screen events during infinity war
like look closely at all the posters of
the Fallen they all depict the victims
as they were in their most recent films
now most look the same in every movie
but Groot you know his teenage Groot
hope Van Dyne looks like she's wearing
her wasp suit but look at Cherie she's
wearing Warpaint and her Panther jaw
chin guard her hairs pulled up this
isn't how she looked an infinity war
this is how she looked back to Black
Panther while fighting kill monger now
I'm not saying these posters show the
characters in their exact final moments
really they're just each of them and
recognizable solemn poses but it is
interesting that Cherie is depicted in
battle gear it could indicate Shuri
having played a larger role in the
battle of akanda than we realized and
that that larger role led to her death
shortly after infinity war when asked
about Charice fate the Russo brothers
said that her status was too much of a
spoiler to reveal
to me that indicates that they have some
substantial story in mind for her in in
game not just a shot of an urn with her
face on it the filmmakers have revealed
that the first act of Avengers endgame
will come from a darker place hinting
that there could be an even worse defeat
instructing the Avengers before they
devise a strategy to reverse Stannis's
decimation imagine a scene early an
endgame that further explores the ending
of infinity war a flashback to the
battle of Wakanda Shuri perhaps after
nearly dying at the hands of Corvus
glaive gets to her feet and gears up for
another way to help defendable conduct
now the focus of that battle was on
vision in the mine stone but even after
he and Corbis rolled into the jungle
fighting still waged on over in the
field maybe some of those outriders
could have charged as far as the city
Shuri could have desperately gone after
them to protect other wakandans like her
Queen Mother ramón de this could lead to
sharise death or a kind of restaging of
Tony Stark and Peter Parker but with
Ramona cradling her daughter as she
dusts away if endgames
first act does come from a darker place
that's um one option I just expected
in-game to reveal shuri's death in some
dramatic or interesting way like if they
didn't show it in infinity war and they
cryptically teased it was too spoilery
to reveal they gotta have something up
their sleeve and if a flashback to her
death scene would steal too much focus
from the endgame narrative perhaps just
the news or the reveal of her death
could carry some other importance like
perhaps sure he left behind some clue
for Bruce Banner or Tony Stark to find
in her records a way to reboot vision
perhaps or some special insight about
the nature of the mind stone and the
other Infinity stones that can lead to
their discovery of a way to bring Thanos
down but my question for you is if we
interpret this posters who means Shuri
for sure is fallen how do you think she
died comment down below with your
thoughts and a special thanks to Philo
who sponsored this video by lo as a
streaming service that gives you access
to over 50 channels including AMC Comedy
Central a a Food Network it's by far the
easiest way to watch shows like South
Park The Daily Show The Walking Dead or
chopped you could start watching within
seconds I now use streaming services
exclusively to get all my content so
Philo it's just perfect for me there's
unlimited recording so you can save as
many
as you want Philo's available on Apple
TV Roku Android iOS and fire TV it's
simple and affordable it's only $20 a
month for all this content I've been
saving over a hundred bucks a month on
my cable bill it has been the best
solution to stay cord free and
commitment free hey there's a special
offer just to you guys the first 50 new
rock stars fans who sign up using our
link will get their first month for free
just visit www.sedar.com ADIZ show in
los angeles darkest timeline comedy and
subscribe to new rockstars thank you for
watching and who would have thought the
color saturation on someone's basis
would give us so much information Oh a
new poster
[Music]